hallo leute heute zeigen wir euch wie
man auf deutsch die uhrzeiten benennt
dafür habe ich heute zwei assistenten
einmal janisch und
einmal manuels küchenuhr los geht's wir
fangen an mit den vollen stunden jetzt
ist es 6 uhr
die zeit vor 12 uhr nennt man vormittag
also diese zeit am morgen ist der
vormittag jetzt ist es sieben uhr
es ist 8 uhr
10 uhr
jetzt ist es 12 uhr am mittag und diese
zeit am mittag die ist etwas anders als
zum beispiel im englischen ich weiß dass
ich im englischen oft verwirrt bin wenn
jemand sagt villmeter nun denn im
englischen heißt nun ganz pünktlich um
12 uhr im deutschen ist dieses wort
mittag jedoch eher eine zeitspanne ich
sagte janitsch treffen wir uns morgen
mittag generell und das kann aber heißen
dass wir uns um 12 oder um 1 oder am 2
treffen und das müssen wir dann noch
spezifizieren die zeit nach 12 uhr nennt
man den nachmittag der nachmittag geht
so ungefähr von 2 uhr bis 6 uhr würde
ich sagen und jetzt ist es ein uhr es
gibt aber für diese zeit am nachmittag
zwei möglichkeiten sie zu benennen es
ist ein uhr oder es ist 13 uhr
jetzt ist es drei uhr oder
15 uhr man kann beide sprechweisen
benutzen aber die sprechweise mit einer
ziffer die benutzt man häufiger im
gesprochenen deutsch englisch und ich
uns verabreden dann sagen wir zum
beispiel treffen wir uns um 3 ja wenn
ihr allerdings vielleicht eine zeitung
lest fernsehen guckt oder an einem
bahnhof seid dann hört ihr meistens die
sprechweise mit zwei ziffern dann würde
es zum beispiel heißen der zug fährt um
15 uhr ab
jetzt ist es übrigens vier uhr oder
16 uhr
jetzt ist es 6 uhr oder
es ist 18 uhr die zeit zwischen 16 und
18 uhr die kann man auch den
spätnachmittag nennen und die zeit ab 18
uhr oder ab 6 uhr die kann man den
frühen abend nennen jetzt ist es sieben
uhr oder 19 uhr
erst die zeit ab 8 uhr ungefähr würde
ich den abend nennen jetzt es ist acht
uhr oder 20 uhr 20 uhr ist eine wichtige
uhrzeit in deutschland denn dann kommt
die tagesschau und die gucken viele
deutschen gerne dass es eine bekannte
nachrichtensendung
schon ist es spät am abend 10 uhr oder
22 uhr
fast schlafenszeit jetzt ist es
mitternacht oder 0 uhr janosch wann
gehst du ins bett zeigt uns das doch mal
auf der uhr
zwischen 2 und 3 wahrscheinlich eher so
10 zu 3
das ist deine schlafenszeit
jetzt zeigen wir euch wie man die zeiten
zwischen den vollen stunden benennt und
hier gibt es tatsächlich in
unterschiedlichen regionen in
deutschland unterschiedliche
sprechweisen ich zeige euch jetzt mal
wie ich die uhrzeiten benennen würde und
ich glaube wenn ihr das lernt werdet ihr
auch in den meisten regionen in
deutschland verstanden jetzt gerade ist
es fünf nach
110 nach 1
es ist viertel nach eins
das ist normalerweise nicht die uhrzeit
wenn die kirchenglocke läutet es
ist zwanzig nach 1
es ist fünf vor halb zwei
jetzt ist es halb zwei
man kann auch sagen
31 oder ein uhr 35 so würde man es zum
beispiel am bahnhof benennen oder
vielleicht im fernsehen im normalen
gesprochenen deutsch sagt man allerdings
meistens fünf vor halb halb oder fünf
nach halb zwei
was ist
20 42
das ist viertel vor zwei
am bahnhof sagt man 13 uhr 50 im
gesprochenen deutsche würde man zehn vor
zwei sagen
und jetzt
25 nach halb zwei falls ja jetzt ist es
542 dar
auch zu diesem video werden wir wieder
interaktive übungen vorbereiten in
unserem mitgliederbereich könnt ihr zu
all unseren videos interaktive übungen
machen und heute geht es dabei speziell
um die uhrzeiten und wie man die auf
deutsch benennt wenn ihr also noch etwas
mehr zu diesem thema und zu anderen
themen üben möchtet dann werdet gerne
ein mitglied von easy german damit
unterstützt der unsere arbeit und euer
deutsch lernen jetzt zeigen wir euch mal
die regionalen unterschiede tatsächlich
spricht man im nordwesten von
deutschland etwas anders als im osten
und im süden von deutschland
ich habe euch gerade gezeigt wie man im
norden und im westen spricht man bezieht
sich dabei immer auf die nächste volle
stunde viertel nach fünf sagt man denn
dieses viertel ist also die nächste
volle stunde ist die fünf ich sage also
viertel nach fünf im süden und im osten
von deutschland würde ich jedoch zur
nächsten vollen stunde zählen das heißt
die zeit zwischen 5 und 6 wird immer auf
die sechs bezogen und die sechs ist hier
die referenz diese uhrzeit heißt zum
beispiel im süden und im osten von
deutschland 4 6 und 4 6 heißt man hat
eine viertelstunde von der sechs voll
und wenn man jetzt weitergeht würde man
sagen halb sechs das sagt man
tatsächlich in allen regionen
deutschlands
und wenn man noch eine viertelstunde
später ist dann sagt man im süden und
osten
drei viertel
46 vor 6 das ist etwas verwirrend ihr
könnt euch aber vielleicht merken dass
ihr einfach eine sprechweise lernt und
die meisten deutschen verstehen euch
damit oder wenn ihr ganz präzise sein
wollt dann sagt sie einfach die exakte
uhrzeit so wie man es am bahnhof sammeln
würde 17 uhr 45
damit könnt ihr nichts falsch machen
während wir dieses video aufgenommen
haben wurde es immer ein dunkler und
windiger und jetzt hat es auch noch
angefangen zu regnen iranische was ist
deine abschluss botschaft an unsere
zuschauer also ihr lieben lernt fleißig
und tschüss
und wenn ihr noch mehr lernen möchte
denkt daran dass wir auch zu diesem
video wieder interaktive übungen
vorbereitet haben für unsere mitglieder
und wenn ihr ein mitglied werden möchte
findet ihr all die links hier unten
danke fürs zuschauen danke für die
großartige assistenz janisch und dann
kann manuell für diese wunderschöne
küchenuhr dies ein kleiner riss in der
wand davor das war schon vorher
so
jan ich jetzt machen wir noch einen test
hatte nur das nicht gucken
vier minuten nach halb sieben
ja eigentlich fünf aber gut
10 47
[Musik]
viertel nach fünf
sehr gut sie haben das uhrzeiten diplom